Speaker 1: I want to have a brief update with you
about what's going on in Arizona and in America
first. And with the Arizona gubernatorial
election, it's actually becoming even more
cartoonish and pathetic and humiliating than what
we saw after the 2020 election with Donald Trump,
Carrie Lake, who lost the 2022 Arizona
gubernatorial election. That's it. There's
no other there's. That's the story. She lost her
opponent, got more votes. She is now calling for
a new election. And there are people around her
who seem to be encouraging her. We're going to go
to our first clip. This is from the last whimpers
of America Fest, an event put on by Turning Point
USA. Here is Kari Lake speaking to Charlie Kirk.
And they now want a new election in Arizona.
All that happened is Carrie
Lake lost. Understand that.
Speaker 3: What is the remedy we're asking
for? I think that we need a new election. I
think that there needs to be a new election.
Speaker 2: But we can't have the same clowns
running this election. We can't put it back
into the hands of people who have bungled
the election time and time again. And yes.
Speaker 1: Now that there's an important
little detail in there, which is in some alternate
universe which we might enter in the next clip,
I'm going to show you, by the way. But in some
alternate universe where you get a new election.
You know that if they did the election and
then Kerry Lake lost again, they would just say
the same people ran this election. This election
was just as biased and fraudulent and rigged as
the first one. And we know that that would happen
because it's what it's what we see when they do
recounts and audits. Every single time you get an
audit to the. And again, when you say an audit,
what is it that they want? They do an audit and
it turns out the result was fine, or even that the
Democrat actually won by more. And then they come
back and they say that wasn't really an audit.
All they did was recount the same fraudulent
ballots. We need signature verification. We
need curing. We need sorting and smoking and
grilling. We need to do all these things to
the ballots to figure out whether these should
even be counted, because at the end of the day,
they will adjust their allegation of what happened
simply to fit whatever narrative they need
at that moment. At one point, the problem
in Arizona was people didn't get to vote. And
that hurt Carrie Lake because of tabulators and
power circuits and all these different printers.
People who wanted to vote didn't get to vote.
Then the story shifted to so many people voted
in Arizona who shouldn't even have voted. And it
was. And tons of Republicans voted and their votes
were counted for Katie Hobbs. Wait a second. Was
the problem that Republicans weren't able to vote
or was the problem that Republicans were able to
vote in huge numbers, but tons of their votes
were counted with Katie Hobbs? Which of the two
is actually the problem? And it's both depending
on what's going on. One other really funny moment
from this interview with Charlie Kirk. Kerry
Lake explains her process for hiring attorneys.
And it's it's pretty damn funny.
Speaker 3: And it was a valley
wide ambush is what happened.
Speaker 2: So lutely absolutely 100% and
and they're trying to tell us this is normal par
for the course. Don't insult me, Stephen. Richard,
don't insult my intelligence. We know what you're
up to. And we're going to we're going to put you
on the stand and ask you a few tough questions.
So I feel very confident. My team is great. My
attorneys are true patriots. We had attorneys who
did walk away because the left is threatening them
with their ability to make a living and practice
law. And some of our attorneys said, look, I
got mouths to feed. I can't do this case. I don't
want to be sanctioned. So I really love I got to a
point where I said, I'll take anybody. We'll take
better call Saul to. Come on right here. Are you a
patriot? Are you willing to fight? Are you willing
to risk everything on this very important case?
And that's who we have assembled, true fighters.
And we're going to court tomorrow and Thursday.
And we hope for a quick, you know, ruling on.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's evident that absolutely
anyone can be Carrie Lake's lawyer that that
we figured out. And that is abundantly clear.
So there's not going to be a new election.
Katie Hobbs is going to be the governor of
Arizona. Katie Hobbs one Carrie Lake loss. But
before we completely get off of this topic,
I have to show you someone who truly does
seem to be living in an alternate universe